some millionaire theme our dispelling
the mythology that wealth inequality is
unfair it's mythology use socialist
little twerps yeah seriously it's crazy
out here the number of people who are so
under educated about the actual
statistical facts in America today
eighty eight percent of America's
millionaires are first-generation rich
started with nothing less than one
percent of them are entertainers
athletes and actors so being famous
doesn't you know usually isn't the most
most highest probability way to become a
millionaire it's working and saving and
living on less than you make that's what
almost all of them share so we're
interviewing them to dispel the myths
number one number two to let those of
you that aren't yet millionaires know
that you can do it and number three let
you know what they've done to get there
so you can emulate copy or study their
best practices Leslie is with us
Leslie's in Spartanburg South Carolina
hey Leslie how are you hi Dave I'm great
it's an honor to talk with you today you
too so what is your net worth about 1.9
million okay very cool and what is that
primarily or what's the mix on that
what's it invested in we have our house
is worth about three hundred and eighty
thousand we still have a forty thousand
dollar mortgage on it okay but the rest
is invested in mutual funds stocks and
bonds through retirement plans and so
forth gotcha
and how old are you I am 60 and my
husband is 60 as well very cool how much
of the 1.9 million did you inherit about
eighteen thousand maybe okay alright and
so you started working somewhere around
thirty or forty years ago
and what has been here average household
income through those years
well average we started very small
because tom was in school as was I at
one time so I would say average through
the years it's probably about 250 to 275
thousand dollars of course is much
greater now what is it now what's the
high point our annual income is about
eight hundred and forty thousand dollars
a year awesome very cool so what is the
career fee
what's the career field that's producing
that well I'm a retired human resource
manager I do some small small consulting
job still here and there but not not
much it's really Tom's trajectory as a
physician as a specialist that got us
there okay so he's a doc all right
what kind of doc is he he has a
gastroenterologist hasn't been
practicing for a lot of years okay Wow
Wow on top of his meal big-time
yes okay so obviously his degree was MD
plus and your degree is in what my
degree is in labor relations and human
resources management I have a master's
degree okay very cool and what kind of
GPAs did you to run let's see Tom's
undergraduate GPA was probably 3/7 or
3/8 in medical school it was a 3 6 or
3/7 my undergraduate was a 3/8 now okay
cool
somehow I doubt any of his patients ever
ask that they want to know you know what
his record is on not making mistakes
yeah that they want to know for sure
okay how much how much of this wealth is
due to you having borrowed money to
create wealth we had to borrow seventy
thousand dollars to go through to get
Tom through Medical School
I borrowed 20 to get through my first
year of graduate school but applied for
a teaching assistantship the second year
and got free tuition but in terms of
borrowing to invest to create wealth you
didn't it was only education education
only okay very cool now because this
income is obviously out of whack
I mean it's awesome and I am so proud of
you guys how much of the 1.9 has come
just in recent years since you got this
huge income that is an I knew you would
might ask that and I did want to say
that our situations a little
non-traditional and that we were not
able to start saving until later in life
and that was in our 30s so we have been
putting away as time has gone on we've
been putting away a big percent what we
have been earning and in those
increasing earnings that savings has
been increasing as well so we had a
shorter time period than most people
yeah see but you started and you've been
saving for 30 years yes yes okay I'm
sorry
we act in the light out of the 1.9 how
much of that has come in the last five
years say probably let's see I'm
calculating quickly maybe 300,000 okay
so it's been more steady it's not it's
not like all at the last minute here
okay oh okay that's what I was after all
right that's cool all right
so what part has giving played in your
all's financial plan through your life
well as soon as we finished school and
were employed we have always been
members of a church and we have given
annually pledge to our church and we
continue to do so we also give to other
charitable organizations that that stir
our passions and we feel are worthy and
appropriate and need our help and what's
the most expensive pair of blue jeans
you ever bought probably about forty
five dollars okay all right and before
you were a millionaire what was them how
many new cars did you buy maybe three
okay but we keep art we keep our cars
for 10 to 12 years we drive the heck out
of them since then we've only I own a
six I Drive a 16 year old car tom has a
ten-year-old truck and another car we
had to recently buy with used okay now
not counting medical books how many
books a month or a year do you read or
Tom rate none a lot
I read mostly investing books as well as
crime drama he probably hmm maybe 40 50
Wow
I'm thinking yeah we have a I have to
take our books to the library to donate
them every few months and we just we
have too many okay big readers not not
as much TV time then very little TV no
yeah cool thank you so much for sharing
this absolutely fabulous what is your go
ahead go ahead
I think it's really important for other
people to know how very possible that it
this is for them if they read and just
educate themselves simply on investing
and are careful if you if you live small
even though you're making big it's very
very doable yeah very cool very cool
nice nice talking to you you're
absolutely fun absolutely rock stars
great American success story a lot of
fun
hey you guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
are enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and
did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right it's
kind of better than
I'm kidding I'm kidding so subscribe and
there's lots of videos about life and
money so while you're at it if you want
to check out a video then you can check
out how to do a monthly budget it's one
of the best videos out there
you